- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy,
and I'm here with Grace Hoyt,
head of Account Security
Partnerships at Google
to talk a little bit about online safety.
Welcome, Grace.
- Thanks for having me, Sal.
- So let's just start at the basics.
What is online safety
and what's the worst that could happen?
- As we spend more of our times online,
we think about online safety
in a way that people can go
about their work or school
or personal activities online
in a way that they feel safe and secure,
and a big topic in this space that we like
to provide guidance on is
something called online scams,
and in particular, how to avoid phishing.
- Now, phishing, spelled with a P-H,
P-H-I-S-H-I-N-G, what is that?
It starts to evoke, people
are maybe fishing for me.
- That's right, Sal.
Phishing does have the namesake
from the word with fishing, with an F,
but this phishing we're talking
about is a attempt to impersonate someone,
a trusted source, or reach you via email,
phone, or call, and try to get access
to someone's personal information,
such as their bank account information,
their passwords, or address,
and things like that.
So phishing is a way to sort of bait
and hook someone in to giving
up personal information.
Unfortunately, about 80%
of all cyberattacks begin with phishing.
So this is something we
think it's really important
for people to be able
to spot and recognize
on their own so that this
doesn't happen to them.
- And what form do these
phishing attacks take?
- So these can be emails
impersonating a trusted source.
These can come in the
form of spammy text links
or phone calls.
One of the most important
tips that we like
to advise people is to
not click on a URL link
before verifying that it really
is the source you're trying
to get to.
So it's always best to actually
go directly to a website.
For example, if you're
trying to reach your bank
or track the delivery of a package,
type that directly into your URL,
as opposed to opening a
suspicious link right out
of your email inbox or text message.
Now, if you want to
actually look more closely
at a link before clicking on it,
on mobile, you can press and hold down
on the URL and look for suspicious aspects
of that link, or typos,
but you can also just use the option
to go directly to that link yourself,
as opposed to opening it out
of something that looks suspicious.
- Okay, so this has
definitely happened to me
in the recent past, where
I get these text messages
for, "Fraud alert for your bank account,"
and sometimes it's from a bank
where I don't even have a bank account,
so they're just trying to
see if I happen to be...
"Someone just charged $10,000."
I'm like, oh, my god,
and then I look at it
and the URL looks a little bit shady,
and to your point, you
have to really confirm
what the URL is, even if
it doesn't look shady,
and on mobile, you can press and hold.
Sometimes you get these emails that, "Hey.
"Someone has just done the
following on your Amazon account.
"Go log into your Amazon account here,"
and it's probably a link
to a fake Amazon website.
You type in your credentials.
Now they can actually log
into your Amazon account
or your banking account, or whatever else.
- Absolutely.
So unfortunately that's oftentimes
a way that folks are trying
to grab that password
and have you hand it over to them.
So you're exactly right, Sal.
So we do recommend that people
go straight to that URL.
- Well, thanks for that.
I think we're all a little bit less likely
to get phished and get hooked.